Non, absolument non
et Gomorrhe parle d'un système d'un
système
le criminel est
cinéma et généralement films de genre oui
basé sur
des histoires qui apportent la lumière de la vérité
inconfortable sur les systèmes sur les systèmes
donc des criminels à travers le monde
les acteurs du monde entier devraient
avoir peur mais
Nous sommes
acteurs nous représentons une des séries
le plus beau fabriqué en Italie
et surtout fabriqué en Europe dans le
ces dernières années donc nous n'avons pas
absolument peur de
aucun je suis né à Naples
centre mais j'habitais alors dans un petit
village de banlieue appelé
Mugnano de Naples et
mais je suis napolitain à tous égards
alors j'aime ma terre et je cherche
faire connaître ses beautés
via mes réseaux sociaux et
j'invite surtout ceux qui ne l'ont pas
je n'ai jamais eu le plaisir de le visiter
fais-le absolument parce que Naples est
Maginifique
Il y a tellement d'acteurs qui ont
J'ai fait partie du projet Gomorra Più
de 300 400 comédiens professionnels et
non et oui il y en a beaucoup qui viennent
des quartiers du centre de Naples
certains viennent de banlieue, d'autres de régions plus éloignées
décentralisé de Naples donc
euh Disons qu'il y a beaucoup d'acteurs qui
ils représentent l'énorme
talent d'acteur
Bell qui a dit ça
ce système criminel ou Gomorrhe
ils le représentent parce que peut-être
ils ont vu de leurs propres yeux ce que
il peut faire ça à de bonnes personnes
système pénal et à travers
Ça, cette méchanceté, cette colère
C'est peut-être plus facile pour ceux qui l'ont vécu
notre
dis-le, et bien, il y a deux saisons
différent entre le premier et le deuxième la
dis d'abord que je fais toujours le
comparaison avec une femme ou avec un amour dans
général puisque la première saison est une
un peu comme une fille
que tu sais si soudainement et dont
Tu meurs follement parce que tu ne le fais pas
tu t'attendais à ce qu'il soit si beau pendant que
la deuxième saison, c'est un peu comme
eh Cette même femme que tu aimes et que tu as
bien-aimé dont tu es tombé amoureux
tout à coup, cela devient maintenant le
femme qui est avec toi à tes côtés qui
tu sais mieux que tu n'apprends à savoir
toutes ses nuances, toutes ses
avantages et tous ses défauts donc
Je ne pouvais pas choisir, je les aime tous et
deux oh
monami tu dois absolument le regarder
deuxième saison de Gomorrhe ce
la saison sera beaucoup plus complexe
beaucoup plus dur ce sera plein de coups
scène et et surtout pour combien
c'est à propos du mien
personnage, vous en verrez un plus loin
L'évolution de
Jenny, tu verras une Jenny plus réfléchie
qui a beaucoup appris de ses parents
les erreurs seront nombreuses
plus stratégique C'est peut-être le mot
approprié
[Musique]
Bonjour; salut